thieves come on out Ted hey shel Ted 10x
having me welcome it's a pleasure so Ted
talk to me a little bit about what is C
of thieves
yeah so we feel that we've made the
pirate game you've always wanted when
you think about saying around the open
seas you and your crew of crew mates
basically it's pirates I can be mr.
Goonies what are some of the things that
you're showcasing here at e3 in the game
yes if anyone who didn't see the
briefing yesterday we showed off great
new features like riddle map storms and
firing yourself at a cannons or a common
favorite pastime yeah pretty nice now I
had to ask the same question to Forza
Motorsport what are some of the things
some of the features that you added in
to focus on the PC experience yeah so
we've got things like 4k unlocked frame
rates or everything you expect but we've
also bought our gameplay footage in 21
by 9 as well my personal favorite your
or your favorite resolution one of the
top three favorite resolution through
there with 32 by nine and sixteen by
nine as well premiere so tell me a
little bit more about the PC version
obviously it's probably a challenge to
try to develop for two different devices
at once yes we decided to change our
approach to the game we're actually
building both versions in parallel
because we felt that's how we deliver
the same game on the same day so it's
not a port from one device to the other
correct yeah we thought was really
important just to build them together
from from the very beginning one single
code for one single co-pastor yeah
awesome well I know a whole lot of
people here are curious to get their
chance to play it is there an official
release date or a opportunity for them
to play it yes it becoming to both
platforms in early 2018 but right now we
have a technical alpha you're welcome to
come sign up we have thousands of PC
players playing already so yeah come
join us see our thieves calm once again
Ted Timmons awesome thank you very much
thank you guys
see of Thieves calm now this nice